the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode good
morning everybody uh happy tuesday it's
march 15th
and you know i'm excited to be here
today you know despite everything that's
going on in the world you know
life goes on and you know the markets
have been
very fascinating for the last
you know last few weeks and you know the
price of crude oil fortunately is
starting to come down a bit we're
trading in the 90s and we're going to be
talking about today is you know becoming
a profitable trader and using order flow
you know it's always fascinating when
you know my wife's not into
trading into the markets at all and
when she starts asking me about the
markets you know i know that it's we're
in interesting times and in today's
presentation
what i'm going to be talking about is i
got there's a few main points that i
wanted to cover today
is you know how to avoid the really dumb
mistakes nearly all traders make each
day
okay and then i'm going to talk about
what every trader needs to know about
order flow trading
and lastly i'll be talking about order
flow strategies that you can quickly and
easily master to become a more
proficient trader because you know at
the end of the day
i i talk to other traders especially
people that are
i don't say new to trading but i've been
struggling in their trading and
you know something that i've
there's there's common denominators
right and one of the things that i've
realized is people like to over
complicate things right trading doesn't
have to be so complicated and especially
when people start thinking about order
flow since it's it's kind of a new
concept for people you know everyone is
just so used to looking at a bar chart
that you know they they think that when
they got to look at things like the
volume that's being traded
like oh my gosh you know i don't i don't
have the mental capacity or i just don't
have the time to to do that and it's
really not that difficult now for those
of you that are new to one of my
presentations i just want to talk
briefly about who i am you know just so
you understand where i'm coming from and
where the information that i'll be
teaching you today where i learned that
from so
again my name is michael baltos and i've
got you know over 25 years of
professional trading experience
and i started on the cme floor the
chicago mercantile exchange back in the
early 1990s
with dean witter reynolds i literally
started at the bottom of the business as
as a runner okay and
that is how people would get started in
the business oftentimes that you know
that didn't have
you know straight a's or graduating the
top of their class that would be you
know selected to go work at a goldman
sachs or something like that i literally
worked my way up right i had to climb
the corporate ladder so to speak after
a few years on the floor i joined edf
man the big english trading company has
been around for you know over 200 and
almost 50 years now
as you know on the global macro
trading desk in chicago
after that i joined commerce bank in
chicago again as i'm a futures guy i
trade futures you know being from
chicago if i was from new york i'd
probably have traded stocks but
you know futures are a great instrument
i became a licensed ux trader at
commerce bank i was one of only a
handful of people in chicago at the time
in the early 90s early 20 late 90s early
2000s that was able to trade urex
directly
with the exchange as opposed to having
to go through a broker
after commerce bank i joined cargill
right the big u.s commodity trading firm
i spent four years there as head of the
futures trading desk and you know
eventually they sent me out to singapore
to set up another trading desk after
my four years at cargill i took some
time off then eventually i joined jp
morgan in singapore and i spent
about eight years there um as vice
president of futures trading uh futures
trading
you know then after i got married had a
kid you know i decided you know i don't
want to i know how to trade but i don't
want to be doing this
coming in at
six in the morning staying there till
five at night
every day as i felt like i was going to
you know basically kill myself um you
know so i said you know there's there's
more to life than
you know working at a bank and
you know answering to a boss you know
that's what trading gives you trading
gives you freedom gives you that ability
to say you know what i could do this on
my own and and i left
and i started up order flows.com in 2015
and we're going on our seventh year now
you know so it's it's very good so all
the information that you're going to be
learning today you know derived from all
that years of experience of trading that
i've gained over the years now i said
you know in 2015 i left jpmorgan i
started up orderflows.com
and we released the order flows trader
actually the new version i forgot to
update this slide is order flows trader
5.0 we just released it about a month
ago
so you can see you know we're been
around for seven years we're already on
the fifth integration of the order flows
trader software which makes analyzing
the order flow
very easy to do as you're going to see
in this presentation now the reason i
just talk about that is because you know
the charts and tools that i use
in this training are generated from my
order flow software
so you know but really i just want you
to see what to look for because you know
a lot of people now you know order flow
is almost becoming mainstream you know a
lot of software providers do have a
basic version so i want you to see how
quickly and easily you can apply order
flow to your trading to make better more
informed trades now if you want to take
your order full trading to another level
that's where i'm going to come in that's
where i'm going to help you and one of
the best ways to do it is to read my
book that i wrote called trading order
flow
if you stick around to the end i'm going
to show you how you can get that for
free it's a 150 page book it's a simple
um download i'm going to show you how
you can get that
so
again you know it's
order flow is a special tool i've helped
a lot of traders over the years
by
showing them what to look for but more
importantly
give them the tools that they need to
make trading easier right and you can
see what people are saying you know
you know the software
makes it remarkably helpful
because they can clearly stop see what's
happening in the market right it's not
just about looking at a chart and trying
to guess is this market going to go up
or down now you could look inside
the bar and see you know is there
aggressive buying is there aggressive
selling is buying drying up is buying um
stopping because there's heavy volume
etc there's so much uh information that
order flow gives you in a chart
and remember
the more complex the methodology the
more psychological impediments develop
the hinder your trading you're going to
misinterpret data or you're going to be
confused to the point that
inaction becomes more likely you're
going to skip trades oh you know i don't
know what's going on because you know
i've got all these different indicators
simple and obvious is always better than
complex and convoluted order flow is
that way simplicity is best
now begin you know before we begin just
a brief disclaimer right you know we all
we're all adults in the room right we
understand that risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
our financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading okay so
basically don't trade with your rent
money so to speak now there are many
ways to trade the market okay you have
technical analysis
you have fundamental analysis you have
cyclical analysis you have order flow
analysis which is what i'll be talking
about today and again you know this is
not a comprehensive list of the
different ways to trade markets you know
i know people that swear by
astrology when they look at the markets
you know i'm not one to judge but
that's what helps them make their
decisions so be it
but order flow is the way that i trade
and it's the way that you know i think
that if you were to add it to your
trading it's going to help you immensely
so the first thing i'll talk about is
how to avoid the really dumb mistakes
nearly all traders make each day
and
that mistake in my opinion is they focus
strictly on price right they're just
looking at one thing in the market and
that is price while price traded you
know 42 27 okay
they're now trading 42 27 and a quarter
they're just
focusing on that they're not looking at
the bigger picture right they're not
seeing where the other
um
ships are so to speak right if you look
into the telescope right you just get
the one you could just see that one
little bit of information
really what you need to do
is take a step back and see where
everything else is in the market that's
happening all right now
if you're not familiar with an order
flow footprint chart this is what it
looks like and you can see there's just
so much information at first
it does look intimidating because a lot
of people aren't used to it now you
could still have your candlesticks you
can see i still have candlesticks going
on in here to
help you understand you know what is
going on but when you see what's
happening
in the bid and the offer the volume
that's being traded on the bid in the
offer the relationship of that trading
where the heavy volume is coming in it's
going to make your decisions
a lot easier right you can take
you know candle setups
that now you're able to confirm with
what is happening in the market based on
what is actually trading in the market
and how it's trading in the market
so
what makes order flow analysis different
from other forms of analysis is that
it's not just price
right all these other indicators that
you go through you know you open up your
your charting software they've got oh we
got 500 different indicators so what
if
they're all based off of price they're
all derivations of price how many
different ways can you cut it right you
need to be looking at the other
information which is the volume that's
traded but not just the volume
but the volume that's traded on the bid
and the volume that's traded on the
offer right because it's important
because markets
trade in a two-way auction right for
every buyer there is a seller right you
can't have a trade if everyone is just
sitting on the bid
and nobody wants to buy from the offer
right nothing's going to happen it's
going to stay there it's when somebody
crosses the bid offer
moves their bid from
current bid to the offer price to buy it
from the offer that's when you have a
trader when a seller goes down and hits
the bid that's when you're going to have
a trade
so
not all traded prices are the same right
different quantities trade at each price
level right some prices might have
30 contracts traded some
some contracts might have
two contracts traded some prices might
have no contracts traded right but
you're not going to see even if there's
no contracts that are traded you're not
going to notice that in a normal bar
chart but if you're looking at a
footprint chart you're going to know
you're going to see that right away so
volume expresses interest and enthusiasm
in the market more importantly it
reveals conviction in the market
remember price alone
leaves a lot to be desired yet traders
love to draw support and resistance
levels
based on nothing other than price so how
is that accurate right well if you take
a second and you look up you know what
is support and resistance defined
well support happens when more buyers
appear
resistance is when more sellers appear
okay you have selling interest that's
what's causing your resistance just as
you're buying interest which causes
support it's not that you just have
it trades down there and then moves up
what happened when a trade down there
right you need that volume to come in
so
because of order for analysis traders
now know that markets don't always
reverse based off support and resistance
levels right the the whole concept i i
see a lot of traders you know posting
charts everywhere online that's
available i mean i see them even on on
instagram now but you know you got
facebook
you got twitter everywhere people love
to
post their charts and you know oh this
is a sport level there's a resistance
level well there's more than just
support resistance in the markets
there's also price rejection
okay where
traders
stop trading at a price because it's too
expensive or they stop selling
because it's too cheap
and if you're looking at a normal bar
chart how are you going to be able to
tell right people will say well yeah you
know i had this wick up here and then
the market sold off you know so you got
price rejection here well do you know
what's price rejection do you know what
support now of course that would be just
splitting hairs i mean market is going
to have the same reaction but why didn't
the market sell off here on this big
wick why didn't the market sell off here
or here or here
that's where
looking at the actual order flow
is going to help you as a trader
because now you can see
how it traded there okay so you can make
a better decision where you can see what
happened here you can see what happened
here you can see what happened at any of
these big tops of these big wicks right
that would be actionable now if you're
looking at the order flow chart
well it's very obvious here if you know
how to read order flow when you get up
to the top of this bar right there's a
few bearish things and i'm not gonna
make this a conversation today about
delta about imbalances about point of
control
um you know i want you to take away some
information right and this is
information here so at the top of this
bar you have what's called an exhaustion
print right you see six contracts traded
now this is e-mini's yesterday
now granted we're in a very volatile
time in the market market's jumping
around a lot
and volumes are
i don't say lighter but they're more
spread out right volatility
in the market right what causes
volatility
is
the market's looking to transact its
volume right so even though this con
this bars got 4 000 contracts traded it
took a it took you know almost uh
what is that
seven handles
you know 42 33 all the way up to 4240
for you know the trading to be done
okay so that's what volatility is is
basically the market moving to find um
buyers and sellers that i can transact
that but when it got up here it got up
to its swing high
right that was you know on the earlier
chart right up here right 42 just almost
42 40.
where was the buying
all right because for the market to go
higher right you need aggressive buyers
you need buyers coming in lifting the
offers
well you got some decent volumes up here
right 241 144 184 122 172 134
and 71
and then six
six
what is that you know that that's like
nothing
you know earlier in the tops of these
bars you're getting 27 20 38 38
6. all right it just dropped off the
cliff here went from 134 cut in half to
71. cut that in
you know
i what is that 80 down to six
so there was just
lack of buying that's price rejection
also known as exhaustion right
if you're just looking at a normal
footprint chart
maybe you can see that right now the
order flows chart will highlight that
area to you okay now you know it's it's
interesting because you know when we
released the order flows trader software
years ago
the first versions you know this is one
of the tools that we had in there and
all of a sudden now most software has it
right we're going to highlight those
exhaustion prints to you
and
people weren't really looking at what
was happening at the edges of the bars
right but it's very important
information
now if you're at a swing high and you
see lack of buying
and you see the market reverse down
closes down
what do you think is happening okay ask
yourself well we just hit a swing high
there's lack of buying
at that swing high markets reverse now i
know here that there's a lack of buying
by the exhaustion right people are tired
of buying right they're rejecting these
higher prices
as opposed to you know a market that you
know here's got 27 came off and rally
back up made that new high this high
held and came off so
you know it's about putting the pieces
together
of the market puzzle so that you can
understand really what's happening in
the markets
okay so again e-mini's yesterday
most of these charts are from yesterday
i think i got a couple charts from this
morning
now
you know oftentimes right you're going
to see a market
hit a swing high
come off come all the way back up come
off again right a nice double top well
how do you know to sell it
okay i mean that's really what you want
to know as a trader well
okay if there's a way that i know
well
you look at the volumes
okay i mean it's it's quite simple right
it doesn't take a lot to understand now
definitions of double tops do they have
to be exactly to the tick or can it be a
tick or two
again for me i'm fine as long as it's
within a tick or two you know ideally
i'd love to see it exactly at the same
price level but if it's within a tick or
two of the previous swing high or swing
low i'd consider that a double top you
know i know some people like to uh
nitpick
so we hit this first double we've heard
not first double top we put our first
high
okay you got some negative delta minus
39 you see the volumes are traded 42 on
the offer side
come back up within a tick here
it's got nine all right again volume is
kind of light there it's almost an
exhaustion print
market comes off nice strong negative
delta
228 okay then market comes back up here
you almost got this triple top here
right 41 95 and three quarters it trades
starts coming off now this bar has got
positive delta
but then the next bar
negative delta okay next bar opens up
doesn't even trade anything on the offer
side it's a zero so we call a zero print
market trades down big negative delta
okay so
first time you hit the
highs here second time you came back up
selling came in
third time you came back up although the
selling wasn't
initiated on the bar on the high or the
swing you know the second attempt up to
the double top came in immediately on
the second bar we got zero here right i
got no follow-through buying coming in
instead what you have is this bar opens
up and it's just selling hitting the bid
hitting the bid hitting the bid how do i
know it's i had zero here all right it's
telling me there was no
uh what do i call it cross trade right
when the market opened up nobody was
interested in buying lifting the offer
everyone was just interested in selling
so you have that zero print there
obviously you got the big negative delta
so what do you have okay you got your
high you made your first attempt selling
came in second attempt
took two bars but you can see the
selling come in
what do you think is going to happen do
you think the market is going to turn
around and come back up well we just had
that selling come in
chances are it's going to continue right
you know an object in motion is going to
continue in motion
what happens that's your opportunity to
get short by recognizing that lack of
buying coming in here off this double
top right here and coming back up here i
guess this would be the third time
rather coming back up
and it sells off now it did rally back
up a bit just within a tick of this
point of control from earlier but
you should just be sitting here waiting
for this market to break down right here
at 92. now i know a lot of people that
trade double tops they'll you know
they'll take the swing low here which is
way down here 41 you know 86 and a half
right because you hit your your high
came off went back up and say well
classic way to trade a double top is
when you take out that in between swing
low
well where would you rather be short up
here at 92
or down here at 86 i mean they're both
winning trades but
i'd rather be short at 92 than at 86 it
gives me an extra six points
all right so
you know you want to be focusing if
you're just focusing on price this is
where you're gonna be getting short
right here the classic sense but if
you're reading the order flow you could
be getting short right in here as you're
starting to break down after attempting
that double top
okay so here we got a swing high market
sold off went back up sold back off
right how do you know to sell that
well
what's happened
okay
when you come you're making that move
right back up here well a few things
happen
all right you've got your
exhaustion print here right people
aren't interested in taking it higher
right you're seeing four contracts trade
up here well earlier you had 27 over
here you got 18. you got 83
you got 19. when you're seeing these
this lack of volume occurring
as the market is trying to go higher
you should be thinking in the opposite
right well
okay the market is rallying but the
buying is getting weaker what do you
think is going to happen well eventually
it's going to reverse and sell off
which it did
okay and and the clue is just right here
just this one little
number the four the four contracts that
trade well there's just no
follow-through people aren't interested
in trading anymore
okay
because how do you know that is well
normally you're going to have volumes in
double digits you know 20 30 40 50 60 80
100 200
4.
right on a swing high this is just like
here nine on the swing high
it's telling you people aren't
interested anymore
okay they're not interested in buying it
anymore here they're not interested in
buying it here anymore and again it's
again it's not about analyzing every
single tick that goes through that's
what a lot of people think of order flow
they think of those old movies the guys
sitting around the you know the the
ticker tape machine the vacuum
tube thing looking at the numbers well
they're not analyzing every single take
they're looking for
anomalies in there that's giving them
something to act to take a trade off of
so
you know sort of moving away from price
is
most people think that you know the
price of something is its value
okay well not really okay just because
people put a price on something doesn't
mean it's it's worth it right
and if you ever watch that show american
pickers you know they go around
traveling the countryside going to these
old antique houses you know asking if
they could buy something and then later
they say well you know they put a value
on it right and they have their
imaginary profit well at the end of the
day
once you put a value on something it
doesn't really matter unless someone's
willing to pay you that price for it
right you may be willing to sell it you
know just like the whole beanie baby
craze you know and there's a great show
on netflix about the beanie baby cries
but it's like oh you know i've got this
rare beanie baby you know i've got this
rare
um owl beanie baby it's worth five
thousand dollars well it's only worth
five thousand dollars to the person
that's willing to pay it right you may
think in your head that's what the value
is but at the end of the day
you try to sell it you know i don't know
i don't think you can pawn these things
you go to the pawn shop the guy i'll
give you 10 bucks for it right that's
what the value is to him
even though the value to you is um you
know 5 000. and
in trading
right that's what we call the value area
i mean we we think of value as one price
but really in trading in the markets
there's a whole value area all right of
you know value a high value or low and
an upper range of the value a lower
range of the value and it's the majority
where of trading takes place is that
value area now oftentimes
value areas are going to overlap one bar
to the next not going to be jumping
around value isn't going to move that
much that quickly
right generally
values shift right just like price of
used cars has been going up for the last
two years
they're not making these big jumps all
the time so i mean some months they may
increase a lot but gradually value has
been moving higher
okay but when you do have moves
that are significant
big jumps do you think that's important
hell yeah that's important right that's
your time that you know you should have
probably bought your car
you know before that big jump if you can
sense that it's going to move
now if you're looking at a normal bar
chart can you see value no
you'd be guessing now a way of people a
lot of people like to look at value and
say well
we're in a sideways market so that must
be value
okay well you don't know why it's in a
sideways market volume mark could just
be waiting for more information it could
be consolidating because you know like
this week we got a fed announcement um
you know some markets tend to quiet down
around certain times
and that's where balance is going to
come in but if you're looking at a
footprint chart
you can start to see where value is
forming by the points of control right
points of control in the order flow is
the level where the most volume traded
okay so
that's you know a crude way
but
now that you have now that you're
looking at the volume in the bar
well it's very easy to see where value
is traded right you could add the value
areas to the bars so i know that where
the value is
in the bar right and like i said
oftentimes they overlap each other right
like here right they're overlapping then
other times the gap right the gap
what do you think the significance of
that is i know that value is just is now
gapping up it's almost gapping up over
well did gap up over the immediate
you know value areas here but it's sort
of gapping up over the previous value
area highs over here
so do you think that's significant yeah
that's very significant
this is this morning when the market was
trading you know 4166 i don't know where
we are right now 42 something
okay
this is
on a five minute chart right earlier i
showed you a one minute chart right this
is just a one minute chart now you're a
five minute chart right people always
say markets are fractal right whether
you're looking at value on a one minute
chart it's going to give you that
insight down to one minute chart if
you're looking at value areas on a five
minute chart it's also going to give you
that value
right this is
yesterday around 10 in the morning right
you got gap here value overlapped then
it starts gapping down gap here gap here
well what do you think the market is
doing well value is
gapping lower
by bars and five minute periods okay
that's significant information one
little bit of information right now
again you know
you have the swing low here but you see
no there's a gap here starting to move
lower maybe i should be looking to get
short up here
rather than waiting for it to come all
the way down here you get into your
trade five points earlier
rather than basic traditional analysis
euro currency same things right gaps
gaps gaps as the market's moving down
now of course on thinner markets
you're probably gonna see it's gonna be
a little bit more choppy a little bit
more gappy again this is a euro currency
one minute chart but you can see
as the market is going higher gap
gap gap mark starts moving down gap gap
gap all on the way down
now
the second part i want to talk about is
you know what everyone i think needs to
know
about the sort of the basics of order
flow trading and i'm not talking about
delta plc et cetera i'm talking about
some of the easiest things to see
in the order flow
okay so
what if i were to tell you there's an
easy way to see important things
happening in the overflow see where
prices are rejected or to see where
important volume being traded right
because again order flow is about
analyzing the volume and
with the advents of computers it's all
about making it easier for you
the user
to trade with right you don't want to
make trading so difficult right you
don't want to make it so hard that you
you can't understand and then you're
frozen do i buy or do i sell you want
easy actionable things right and this is
the rally that was there earlier right
sold off rallied up here we sold off
okay how do you know to sell that rally
well the signs are here price rejection
price rejection just this little
indication right here a little
indication here it's telling you you
know what this move up is exhausted just
as it was over here right
exhaustion print exhaustion print these
prices here are being rejected we came
back up we're trying to make another run
up to those prices traders are still
rejecting those prices
again
market went up sold off well why because
traders rejected
the price is up here 42 40 yesterday
they rejected that when we were up there
now what else can help
i just spoke about the value areas right
why not add value areas to your bars
a simple little thing can can really
make your trading a heck of a lot easier
okay
you have a nice gap here what do you
think that's telling you right yeah now
you had a gap down went sideways now
you're gapping back up this was the low
um yesterday here 41. was that 41 52 and
a quarter
then we started gapping up gapping up
gapping up now we're trying to gap down
what do you think the market is going to
do well it's probably going to come back
down look to test these lows
okay
and
by understanding where value
areas are in bars
and where they were previously then
you're going to understand why markets
pull back to a certain level
right i mean a lot of traders if you're
just looking at a bar chart you're sort
of scratching your head well
you know why does this market pull right
back to this level now i do have that
previous point of control right here
which is also a clue but if you're
looking at the value areas
okay we gapped up coming back down we're
trading inside this value area right
mark it went up
sort of rejected these higher prices
came back down trading in the value area
now you got to watch what's going to
happen
well a couple things one we can just
still trade in that value area as time
goes on but that's not going to last
forever we're either going to break down
or we're going to break out
okay and in this case we started
breaking out and there's clues that you
can be looking for that that's happening
obviously you can see the point of
controls in each bar migrating higher
um you know you can see the signs in the
deltas as well you can see imbalances in
the bars
okay but
as you know if
if you've ever done any market profile
analysis right you know that if we come
back into value
and the value holds the market starts
moving away
you can have a nice big move on your
hands and that's what happened here
and if you're looking at a normal bar
chart
well
you're really going to be scratching
your head you know trying to guess these
levels why does the market pull back
here
why does the market pull back here right
this is where looking at the order flow
is going to give you those
entry levels right well if you're
looking at the value area
okay well because you have the value
area
of this bar
it's exposed right i have this area
where the market can come back and test
it right came right back up here and
tested it and then sold off just as this
one over here right right before the gap
down
i could sort of draw this box out coming
out from here this is the virgin
whatever you want to call it the exposed
value area or the virgin value area
right the market came all the way back
up tested it
rejected it and sold off right just as
then you left another one here market
came back up tested it and sold off so
it's rejecting it once
rejecting it twice
what happens the market sells off okay
so
you know simple little tools of knowing
where value is in a bar
knowing where
price is being rejected based off of the
volume
is really going to help you as a trader
right again it doesn't take
complex
mathematical equations oh what's
happened at the price over the last
um 30 bars you know and then you know is
there any
divergence convergence well now you just
look and you can see right well okay
well
there's no lack of trading right up here
okay that's my sign i know that buyers
aren't interested
in taking this market any higher and
that's an easy one right where do you
place your stop well if i'm short off of
this you know my stop is just right here
okay because i know that if it starts
coming back up there i'm going to be
wrong
all right so you know that's
make trading simple
don't try to make it so complex
now
let's talk about some strategies okay
that you can
use to become a better trader now again
this is yesterday in the
e-minis right you see the market's
selling off
it sort of bounces up here so it looks
like it's coming in you know people say
oh this is the um
hammer bar it's very bullish well okay
next bar went up and then the market
sold off a lot okay so
candlesticks are great when they work
but
when they don't work they don't work
right
i mean there's been studies on them you
know sort of the the most candlestick
patterns are successful between about 35
to
forty eight percent
you know the ones that have
high percentages of sixty percent you
know they happen so infrequently that uh
when they do happen you'd probably miss
it well
why does the market come back up here
and just sort of bounces now we can see
there's a few things in here
okay
we can see the exhaustion prints okay
that's a that's a bearish sign
okay but when you start adding other
information add the value areas well i
see i had a gap here
okay so i know it's bearish already
market's starting to run on me even
though it had been running but i know
i'm in a strong downtrend right that's
signifies with these gaps then you start
coming back up
testing that value area low of that
virgin
value area okay and it can't go any
higher two large trade two large trade
now
the beauty of computers computers can do
a lot now right you can actually have
the computers
draw out these areas for you
so you can see where
areas of potential where the market can
come back and test to okay and
these exposed virgin value areas that
are just left here that the next bar
doesn't come back in the next bar often
you're going to see the markets
eventually come back and test those
levels and then when we come back and
test those levels can't get into it then
you start seeing the exhaustion prints
then it's very clear
what's happening right because if you're
just looking at candlesticks you're
thinking oh i got my nice uh hammer
candlestick here i'm gonna get long well
i know that i have resistance right here
and what happened to your lung it
stopped right at that resistance and
then sold off
okay so
you know while you got a bullish
indicator just off the candlestick alone
i know i got resistance here and which
one won the candlestick of the
resistance based off the order flow the
resistance one
right then i'm seeing
signs in the order flow that's telling
me it's still bearish
and then you had a nice sell-off there
here's another
example from yesterday right market sold
off rallied up sold off again
why
right as a trader you always want to be
knowing why
now we got to the low of the day down
there at uh was that 52 and a quarter
traded two lots now there's other things
here in the order flow as well right you
have a delta divergence
i know there's
price rejection down here based off the
the volume that's traded right the two
it's highlighted there
i got positive delta on the low so it's
telling me you know buyers are stepping
in okay but why why some buyers are
stepping in
right at this level right that's what
you want to know well when you start
adding
sort of another layer of order flow okay
and you're looking at the value areas
okay because we did have a gap
between this bar here and this bar going
into these new lows as you made the new
low
because the low was previously here at
53 and we sold off another three ticks
and then we gapped up right between this
bar and this bar in the value areas
rallied all the way up from that low of
you know
all the way up to 65 then we gap here
and we sell off again okay so
add another layer of analysis you'll add
the value areas
that are untested and as you're coming
into these lows here from earlier in the
day
i think it was the previous day we came
down into this area in here you see
these zones here these were virgin value
areas from much
earlier times
okay so i know that
we ripped from these levels earlier so
i'm looking to see if those buying that
buying is going to come in again and it
came in
right
as it came down into these areas where
you have these
um until tested value areas all right
these valuers that hadn't been tested
before now the market's selling off
coming down in here
i'm looking to see what's happening in
the order flow okay you come right in it
we hit the top level here
and there's hardly any volume i mean the
first time you trade 21 second time two
and then the marking jumped from you
know this 52 and a quarter area all the
way up to 65. and lo and behold up here
at 65 what do you got
you got a value area that's kicking off
because the next bar hasn't been
went inside to test it or the next bar
right it's still below that right and as
you saw on the chart
right we sold off from this
this is it right here this value area
coming out of this bar
you know from
62 63 all the way back down into the
50s all right so you know that's how
order flow can really really help you
by showing you these areas that need to
be tested right and
there's a five minute chart
okay again yesterday this is just going
into the close
simple i have this value area here okay
next bar went up next bar went up right
we
traded all the way up from what was that
61 all the way up to 76
came right back down
hit the high of that value area
right here went into it by a couple of
ticks
this is like what 62
62 shot all the way up into the 70s
okay came back down
put in another value area that's hasn't
been tested now this value area here
all right you had a value area but it
was tested it came right into it
all right
in the next bar because you're looking
really for those bars where
it's
hasn't been tested
in the next bar or the next bar right
you're looking for when it comes back in
and test it so you have one here
this bullish one market went up up up
came right down into it right before the
cash closed
traded into that area you know this is
this time the pullback was a little
deeper here it was only pulling in a
couple of ticks here pulled in about two
points
again but you're talking an area from
around 58 down to 57
and then it went all the way back up to
77 so you got to buy an opportunity here
buying opportunity here
where's your stop just on the other side
of the zone
on the wider value areas like this
where's your stop your stop is going to
be
you know
obviously worst case scenario is on the
other side of the zone but you know on
these wider zones
it should go with the point of control
first okay so yeah you're getting long
from here your first stop is here
and second stop is here
this might be your mental stop this one
is your hard stop
okay so if it's again that would only
apply if it's a wider zone like this
these this one's a small zone so i'll
just use the whole value area
so
hopefully you can see that using order
flow is really like
cracking open that oyster right and
finding that pearl
you know you're going to see things that
no one else sees
you're going to see things happening in
the market that other traders are just
not seeing right they're just looking at
the the oyster shell closed but you've
opened it up and you're looking inside
and you got you got the nice pearl right
that's really what you want to do is
take advantage of that
you all that information that is
available to you right the exchange puts
it out this is just plain level one data
all right you don't need level two data
unless you're looking at the depth of
market but order flow
top level data level one you don't need
to go anything deeper unless you want to
look at the the depth of the market
um
you know for your own purposes but for
an order flow footprint chart not needed
so over the last 40 minutes or so
hopefully you'll agree it's been time
well spent i can't cover everything in a
quick training session i wish i could
but it's just not possible there's so
many different exciting things about
order flow that you know for some
traders the first time they learn these
things it's just like
they they had no idea it's just like oh
my gosh you know
it's
it's amazing right i mean i don't want
to oversell it but
it's it's one of those things that now
you can finally understand
what's happening in the markets right
but you know
a lot of times nothing's happening in
the market right a lot of markets exist
to facilitate trade between parties
right counter you know hedging their
risks things like that but
sometimes it's just super duper obvious
that
yeah it's just what i call a slam dunk
all right you could just
you could just see it developing i know
i've seen that happen
over and over i know what to do and you
do it right so i got a special offer for
you so you get everything you need to
know about order flow okay and i got a
very special deal if you act today so
what it is it's the order flows trader
actually it's the order flows trader 5.0
not 3.0 um for ninjatrader 8. and we've
upped it you know we've updated it about
a month ago there's
now like 25 pre-programmed order full
tools that you could use and you know
some of the things are showing you today
the um
the value areas being drawn out right
those zones until tested we have them on
different forms of analysis so you can
draw out these different zones so you
can see how the market's going to react
when it comes back into it and it's
really like taking
looking up you know a trading software
to my brain to your computer looking at
showing you the things that i would like
to see in the order flow telling you
whether it's bullish or bearish right
because you know at the end of the day
having order flow software is one thing
right again you can get order flow
software
you know for
i don't say free but
you know minimal charges
that
just shows you the footprint right and
then it just sort of leaves you out
there
to
go and put it all together
right and
when i created the order flows trader
software i did it to make my trading
easier because there's a lot of little
things i look for in the order flow
you know just like i showed you right
the exhaustion print something so
minutes something so obvious
that it's so obvious you tend to
overlook it
you know sometimes it's like i'm looking
for something and
it's just right in front of you right
and if you don't know what to look for
you're going to miss it
but again having software is one thing
you got to know how to use it so i'm
just going to give you the software and
send you on your way with you know a
five page pdf download
that just shows you you know how to
license it or whatever i provide a lot
of further education because you know i
want you to embrace order flow and
really understand what it is that you're
looking at so you become a better trader
right that's why we're doing this is so
we could all become better traders
so if you act today part of the bonuses
is
the order full trading course which i
created and normally i sell this for
297. there's 20 lessons in there you're
going to get it for free
okay
which
again is is a great deal because you
know you're saving money right i mean at
the end of the day
you know people think oh i got to get
the the fastest computer i got to get
this i can get that you know and then
they look at add up everything they want
to get for
begin trading and next thing they know
they're they're five thousand dollars
in the hole before they even put money
in a trading account you know that's why
i want you to get all the education as
well as just software
so you can get the order flows trading
course but you also get this video
series that i did
for my inner circle there's 56 videos on
advanced workflow analysis
uh tips etc
and the only way you can get that now is
through this offer yeah i don't offer
this for sale anymore
it's it's in the vault you can only get
it through this offer so you know the
software the training the extra videos
it's already sixteen hundred dollars
okay
almost seventeen hundred dollars but
you're not gonna worry you're not gonna
pay that today because
when i created the order flows trader
software right i used to
you know do mentoring and things like
that for people
and i still get offers people say hey
you know just tell me how much you want
and you know for your time and we'll do
something that's that you know what i do
this weekly session for users of the
software right and it's tuesday today's
tuesday so i have it tonight at 7 pm
central time for users
is
it's a live session where i talk about
things i saw on the order flow you know
over the last week or so
and you know how to use the software if
you've got questions about the software
if you've got questions about a trade
you could ask me in this room it's a
live session it's
kind of like an ask me anything but
usually it's just me lecturing because
you know people are like okay what do
you got for me today you know they just
want to sit back and and learn but i i
do get questions in there
and i've been doing this for over three
years i got over 157 episodes you know
obviously
i think you know holidays off like
christmas and new year's thanksgiving
week and stuff like that but it's 157
episodes
on this um
weekly training session and a lot of
extra
gurus out there they want to charge you
extra to teach you how to use their
software which you know should be free
so again you know sometimes people say
oh mike i can't reach you you know i
know you're busy et cetera well
every tuesday 7 00 p.m i'm in this room
you're free to ask whatever you want
michael you know i can i got a new
computer i'm going to change my license
token can you do that simple done
you know i'm there you you know so you
can't say well you know you didn't
answer my email if you have the user and
you have any question i'm always there
every week right so
you can be i can be reached there this
is for customers
now what i discussed today is just a
sample of the forms of analysis that i
talk about weekly okay what's available
in inner circle video series as well but
you're going to learn more about order
flow in the weekly sessions than you
thought possibly you're going to learn
more in these weekly sessions and going
through courses etc because you're going
to see it and explain and if you have a
question you could ask it okay so
you know
add that all up it's close to ready two
thousand dollars but
it's just a one-time payment
of 7.49 no recurring payments you know i
see these people that they charge i'm
gonna charge you 2.99 a month
forever you try to cancel your credit
card
it's still getting charged because now
it's linked to your bank account right i
hate that
you know i got these
apple
music subscriptions that i'm paying for
i don't know what the hell they are you
know anymore i just see them come up on
my credit card 9.99 apple music
um
doesn't no sorry what you know but i
hate that so i don't want you to go
through that either just a one-time
payment 749 go to orderflows.com
now
obviously you will need to pay data fees
if you're trading
real time you need a real-time data feed
and you know any ninja trader fees that
come with it
the software will run it runs on
ninjatrader eight it runs on the free
version as well as the paid version if
you're going to trade through
ninjatrader brokerage or one of their
recommended brokers get the paid version
it will pay off for itself over time
so go to order flows trader
oh sorry orderflows.com5.html
takes it to this page right you see the
link up here orderflows.com off to
5.html scroll down now you can read all
about the order flows trader software
there i do suggest you take some time to
read just click this button right here
click to buy now
get started right takes you to paypal
paypal processes your payment
i don't get your credit card information
i don't want it you know i got enough
stuff going on and
after your payment is processed it does
take
it can take up to you know a couple
hours for everything to get processed
because there's you know you're getting
access to trading courses as well so um
you know the license tokens your logins
for the courses et cetera it's going to
be sent to your registered paypal email
address so whatever email you use for
paypal is the one that you're going to
get it sent to
again it's just a one-time payment of
7.49
so go to orderflows.com5.html
now
special bonus
for
you guys today um with investors expos
you know i appreciate everything anna
does for me and and you know especially
in this time it's a very trying time
with everything going on in the world
give you access to the order flow
playbook
okay which is a course that i did on
order flow right and there's
11 additional trade setups in there that
you will learn and that you could apply
to trading order flow normally it's 297
you're going to get it for free today
so to get started just go to
orderflows.com5.html and you're going to
get the order flows trader software
you're going to get the order flow
trading course you get the order flow
inner circle video series you get access
to the live training
each week as well as if you can't attend
you can watch the replays
or
you know if you want to i don't suggest
people watch 157 episodes but you know
if you're ever bored and you want to go
through you can go through all the
previous episodes and you're also going
to get access to the order flow playbook
okay so you're getting a lot a lot of
value that you're just not going to find
anywhere i mean it's really the the
education that you're getting is
actually more than the software
right and i know people that have bought
this package
just because they want to get the
education right
not so much the orthodox trader software
because they're already using a
different
order flow software right so you know
you really you can't lose with this and
again it's just a one-time payment now
if you want to get my book go to
orderflows.com
booked.html
and you gotta enter your name and email
address
and it'll take you to the download page
where you can download it
okay so
again get started very easy there's the
link right there i've put it in the chat
let me just make sure it's in the chat
here
now you know a question that i get a lot
is from people is
well what if i do nothing am i going to
learn well
yeah you can learn you could watch
videos you could do nothing right now
and a year from now you'll be like oh my
gosh where was i a year ago you know
covet hit two years ago
right
a lot of people got interested in
trading
but
they didn't get the proper education and
in the end right now they're finding out
markets just don't always go up right
markets conditions change
and you know they're they're suffering
for it now you can try and take what i
teach you here today go out there see if
you can do it on your own okay maybe
you know trial and error for the next
few months and perhaps if you're lucky
you start to see some positive results
and you know the ones that
are successful in that way by you know
spending time watching videos youtube
videos jumping around
they already have some sort of
background in trading but if you're
relatively new to trading
and new to order flow
you really want to start at the best
point possible right you take let me
take you by the hand
and walk you through step by step each
part of the process skip that trial and
error stuff
do the work
and you're going to watch as your life
and trading transform right before your
eyes so which option is better for you
right try and do it on your own
do nothing
or let a professional someone that's
traded professionally at very high
levels right big trading firms
investment banks
teach you so get started go to
orderflows.com
html
and you know on that i will end it for
today guys you know thanks for taking
the time out of your day
and you know again i realize you know a
lot of us now sort of going back to the
having to go back to offices for certain
people and you know it's not all about
just sitting at home
doing things right so if you want to
make a change in your life the best way
to do it is
you know get that solid education in
trading
and go from there
so thanks everybody
have a great weekend or sorry great rest
of the week and
have a great weekend ahead thank you and
bye bye
you